[Music]
[Laughter]
honestly
honestly with longer hair oh [ __ ]
honestly if i were to just like get some
tan because i'm i'm i am darker than you
you guys should be like a brother-sister
popping group from japan oh
that's right
five six seven eight don't know
anthony's the dancer no no do not bring
me into this [ __ ] why can't you help
why can't you help because i i retired i
am now vlogger
yes we're all switching anthony's a
vlogger i'm a vlogger now sherry's a
vlogger
i'm a vlogger what'd you say yesterday i
lost my v card
[Laughter]
what can just you know i posted a vlog
and then they're like oh i thought this
was sherry disappointed
because i was in i was vlogging in in
this i could grow out this a little bit
oh i should have shaved a little bob
your hair's so long now i know girl what
the hell
how long do you want to go until it
reached my [ __ ]
but maybe stop at the nipple and then
the belly button
maybe anthony dude
i know why the [ __ ] does he have to look
better than me with a hat on man it's
not fair
high key looks good in everything
because he has that confidence
i know look at he's holding a knife for
no reason that's confidence it looks
good too why does he take all of my
stuff that might get better
but anthony can you rock this oh yeah
i'll take it out
roll up some tissues can you rock the
bloody nose look yeah
no i think no one can rock that that's
distinctive
it's your it's your consistency nelly
with the band-aid that's your signature
look that's his nike switch
are you getting hell in those bleeds in
vegas now oh he's out here dude what the
[ __ ]
the [ __ ] that's like you're mike tyson
well it's dry enough in vegas where the
blood dries up before it drips down
baby it's bleeding but it just dries
before it reaches oh for sure every
single time i go to vegas the morning
after
the partying i blow my nose and just
blood
and not my own blood oh god yeah that's
other people i can't talk about it
really you've been muff diving yeah
honey first of all we're fresh off a
pride month so
oh that's all i gotta say
this is off the record this is free for
the people
do you go a little more ham pride month
you go extra munching is that what
you're trying to say
you should because i'm cookie monster in
these streets
no i'm not i'm really not um i have
respect for myself and others
just for the record uh but it was pride
month off the record
of pride month on top of june 15th the
city opening up
there was a lot going on so it was like
just zero to 100 real quick
you know so we're opening oysters we're
opening oysters raw and grilled
let's go a little tabasco little tabasco
a little bit of
uh horseradish oh you know what oh the
horseradish cocktail sauce
a little jalapenos peanuts too honey i'm
bisexual
save
i thought you were setting it up for a
vaccine have you seen the bisexual couch
i have i have seen the bikes i don't
know oh dude there's a couch
ikea yeah it's [ __ ] ridiculous the
name the bisexual
does the eye have like two dots on it i
thought you were talking about [ __ ]
swedish spelling
e that's funny what's a bisexual couch
because i'm trying to [ __ ] it's got a
dildo on one left seat
and it's a pocket [ __ ] [ __ ]
yeah yeah the flashlights the same
makers of the flashlight
from the people who brought you the
flashlight brought to you by silicon
valley
i'm gonna get turned on your hands
nobody believes you so
when you change or to and nobody nobody
believes
i don't what does that mean this is also
the colors of the bisexual flag fyi
that's tiny
pink blue and purple neon camouflage it
is actually really dope
the actual design itself is really sick
it's scary as [ __ ] though
wait so because it's like being about
being like coming in someone's house and
it's like how handsome
first of all you're you're in a
relationship and i'm single so i like
just
random hands on me i like to feel
handsome everywhere because i i
feel nothing is this intentionally a
bisexual cash yeah it is the idea but
nobody believes you that you're bisexual
basically and y'all can probably admit
that when you hear someone
say they're bisexual you're preposterous
skeptical that's why we need to validate
bisexuality because it is real like
i've never seen skeptic i think porn oh
it's important what about it yeah when i
think of bisexual i go
oh one of my favorite genres of porn
okay
i like it i'll take it what about you
when i think of bisexual i just think
they get
twice the fun okay yeah that's a mistake
you're not a limited
choice person yeah why why why
why put a put up put a put a limit
put why put it
why are people skeptical of it why put
yourself in a box
who's skeptical um no just in general um
that's like the
average response you get well yeah like
people always ask like well who do you
like more
like a girl or a guy yeah who do you
like more or who do you think you're
going to end up with and it's like i
don't know i truly like both equally you
know
for both yeah horny af for both wow
honey af
you're fountaining for both big time
right so then basically it's changing or
and and and no one believes you that's
the thing that scares me about this
couch when you walk into somebody's
house there's hands all over and all i
see is nobody believes
right like if that cushion is in the
laundry
or somebody's sitting here yeah yeah
yeah i just know what it is
like come on next to me no i'm good well
then nobody believes you is in the
laundry and everybody's just confused
yeah yeah everyone wouldn't change or to
ann
man you guys wash your couches huh yeah
no first of all i don't even wash my
[ __ ] overalls i don't know
when the hell i've i watched this like i
got this out of here
my cushions are in the dryer yeah you
just have a skeleton of a couch
i watched the inside slowly i thought
that was a ghost couch you know like
when you see a ghost and nobody believes
you
honestly the the design actually is
really dope or like a free the children
type of it seems scary what does it go
with you know
no actually i've been into the eclectic
style now where
nothing needs to go with anything you
know what uh what is the christmas story
remember the lamp with the leg maybe the
hand couch goes with the leg lamp
oh yeah yeah well you'll poke an eye out
for sure with those hands oh yeah
mickey mouse hands random i don't know
but the hands just hands in general just
shout out to hands
family wait what if you did that but
with the penis yeah
you agree with your whole body there's a
portal like this yeah i've seen a porn
like that's gonna be
just like there's a wait can you move
your penis you can move your penis
without like up and down without you
wait you did it even if it's soft right
now if it's soft it goes more like this
and yeah you have to grow it you're a
dancer
we get it yeah you got you got to get
half masks for it to like do
full movement dexterity yeah oh yeah
yeah
you know what it is it's like a sail you
have to [ __ ] lift the sail first
and then the wind will catch anthony's
dick does this
ah [ __ ] you've been practicing that for
a while
for this moment that presentation for
this moment that's why hello to anthony
i just do that you're the angle too she
was like and then
what's great for camera oh [ __ ] i can do
it
that's it that's all i got okay not bad
hey push the limits y'all
how's it doing oh [ __ ] no i can't do
[ __ ] pass it around pass it around oh
boy
that's all i got oh my god i'm taking it
oh and i'm giving it no i'm giving it
back to anthony
that was so funny i hate it he makes it
how come no
also practice that that's one of those
that's what i was
oh
i hit my head and it's going back to you
kind of erotic
that was like that was that's a porn
category what you just did
that was very nice this uh rim tongue
oh oh that's actually
this is the official bisexual dance
[Laughter]
you i got a question for you talk to me
so do you
jack off like a guy what
guys are very visual right time to jack
off pull up a porno
see what the hell is going on right for
you uh if you
yes or no to that question and then if
it is the dude's way of doing it
what mood gets you in i gotta look at
some dudes
and what mood gets you and i gotta look
at some chicks what catches your eyes
very good question
um thank you thank you thank you thank
you congressman we got clearly
we got a clue there i co-signed and
sponsored the question actually
vote for me what we should be talking
about in government
yeah very good questions because putting
the talk and oh yeah
very good question uh sir nosebleed
um so first of all i
i do enjoy porn but i actually haven't
watched porn in a long time uh so lately
when i masturbate literally last night
i um imagination yes i'm very visual
when it comes to like for example there
is someone who
is the apple of my eye currently
so i kind of please share wait sorry
that came out of my mouth before i
talk to you i envisioned um an
experience with them wow
so i mean that's what it sounds like
when i masturbate
today's video is brought to you by omen
are you sick of all the randos that just
go up into your gaming chat rooms
yup i'm like playing games with my
friends and i'm like all of a sudden who
the [ __ ]
is this troll get the hell out of here
man where's the mod where's the bot
ah we don't have a mod yeah and
sometimes you just need your own oasis
because you're like i wanted this to be
a game with three for my friends and i
got this guy coming
just trolling all the time taking over
my headphones
calling me all these racist things just
talking [ __ ]
nonstop shut up you 12 year olds and
so what all asus is is super dope it's a
free and easy to use add-on for the omen
gaming hub
and it creates a virtual room for you
and up to 15 of your friends
that's a lot it's got low latency
720p 30fps baby and
you can quit worrying about technical
difficulties and arguing over
like who's got the shittiest connection
here because it works good with all of
them
and since you can use voice or text
message and you can just talk to all
your friends in an oasis
oasis is the best way to hang out when
it's hard to meet up and hang out so
make sure you have the omen
gaming hub installed and then get the
oasis add-on to build your own gaming
paradise
so play together watch together chat
together
share together with oasis on the omen
gaming hub and you can try it and
download it for free try the beta
version
at bit dot l y slash oasis
record to download it that's bit dot l y
slash oasis record so and and
uh this person uh they're
in real life or like a real life no real
life person
you're picturing a [ __ ] spaghetti
dinner with them and then you [ __ ]
swipe that [ __ ] off of the table at
olive garden and you [ __ ] them on the
table yes
actually those kind of scenarios i'm
right you get the bread stick and you
can put it on their lips and [ __ ]
literally like unlimited bread sticks
double-sided dildo
so you're a loyal masturbator i'm a
loyal masturbator wow thank you
i'm a monogamous loyal no not
necessarily monogamous because sometimes
there's two people at once
but wow kamala and biden no i
i've done it yet but um i'm trying to
think like
i even to be honest with you i even talk
to myself
i even like whisper like you start
you like oh you're like dirty talking to
yourself i do actually i'm very vocal
just yourself or as
them to you or you do both sides as as
me to them
what now you're playing both parties no
no no no no i wish i haven't booked that
role yet i haven't booked that role
still waiting i'm pinned your roommates
go uh there she goes again
no no that obviously i mean obviously
like
i'll do it in silence um ish
where were you last night take us there
oh i was in my room last night first of
all okay last night i will say that i
was
texting this girl that is not the apple
of my eye but we were kind of flirty
flirty are you in bed are you on a desk
my chair in my bed i'm laying down in
the dark what kind of
what kind of sheets you got what's the
thread count what's the thread count i
have a half of this
yeah i was on this camera on this couch
um if you don't have this couch are you
even bisexual no you know what i mean no
um so i'm in in bed of course it's hot
as hell and i'm topless
you're topless tell us i'm only wearing
underwear because it's literally 800
degrees watch
out the ac on because i'm asian why
would you ever go to sleep with the ac
on you get nosebleeds she has a hand fan
bro okay yeah i have a hand fan first of
all
one of these like that's what i do like
before i'm masturbating i really just oh
[ __ ] set the set the room
i'm embedded i'm texting homegirl but
here's the thing one of these things
no you're texting you're texting oh wait
you got a fan
and the ticks sometimes i do that to
myself when i'm alone but not often
i do like that done to me though boob
stuff yeah but anyway now this is this
is for off the record we'll give it how
do you do that you pretend like someone
else is doing it too your finger comes
out the back like this
you know what's really interesting so
when i'm when i'm masturbating and i'm
touching myself
it's like i'm touching myself at the
same time because especially if i'm
fantasizing about a woman
yeah it's as if i'm also touching her oh
[ __ ]
so it's this like weird dual
lingo duolingo it's like you're touching
a woman but you're touching yourself
because you are a woman but then you're
kind of like playing both
yeah oh no that means that when we're
jacking up we're like jacking up other
dudes now
no no no the other one the other way
around if you were to jack off another
dude
you know you actually know exactly what
he's feeling so you're jacking yourself
off so when you like
when you're when you're like eating out
your girlfriend so he's jacking
me up yeah when you're eating out your
girl you actually don't know what she's
feeling
at all yeah your guest is stabbing in
the dark but if you jack off a dude you
know exactly what he's feeling that's
right
let's do it bart
is gonna gonna jack up anthony but on
the patreon so you all better go there
you jack me i jack you and we see who
wins not the low tears oh my god how fun
that's the new game that's jk party dude
we'll have stopwatches
it is a jk party that's [ __ ] hot i
think that's so hot
that's really hot like just see she's
getting really turned
who comes first who come first is a good
name who are we betting on though
who do you think is gonna go right it's
like mma fight ufc
i think it depends on who's more
comfortable and what
the quicker comer is the one that's most
comfortable i think this dude's gonna
bust quick okay
why because he seems really comfortable
anthony doesn't seem very comfortable
comfortable what do you mean because you
have to first get hard and then they'll
come
you mean in the case of two hetero men i
think what disturbs me is that bart will
want to win so much
well you know who is going to come first
person
yeah that's what i'm saying that's a
good question i think the words both
comfortable
and competitive are being used right now
i think it's like fighting okay because
in fighting right you don't want to get
hurt
you want to hurt the opponent and you
wouldn't the first to knock him out wins
right
so like so if i knock [ __ ] you don't
want to come you don't want to come
first
you want to make him come but you don't
want him to make you come this is where
you guys mess up this isn't about
fighting this is about loving
right right i'm not i'm not a fighter
i'm a comer you're a comer
well okay wait that is a good question
though because because
professional cover okay um without your
instagram bio
a resume right away do we i do want if
we were to do this
it needs to be like arm wrestling rules
right where the other hand is above the
table
but the other hand above the table
there's a stick that you have to hold on
to yeah so you got to keep her
it's not a stick it's the other guy's
waist yeah back in the head yo
but i don't i don't i don't want to see
what you're doing to me though guys
i don't want to see what you're doing to
me and i don't want you to see what i'm
doing to you okay
question where's the eye contact where's
the eye contact forward to forehead
are we going forward the forehead back
of the head like this cheek to cheek
dangerous you're taking it too far man
come on
thank you guys we can we can push it you
know
we just we just we just we just be nice
yeah but it's also just a positional
thing the closer you are the easier it
is
inertia velocity oh that's physical okay
so take me there your last night
what's your fantasy
so this specific girl i'll be honest i
hung out with her
many many times and i always leave with
the regret that i didn't do anything
because at the same time much of a
gentle woman gentle woman
um not even that i think there's a lot
of factors right now i
really want to be single so with that
it's like you don't get too invested
i don't want to start something all love
is too deep right i don't want to start
something i can't finish and maybe
that's unfair to her etc
you could finish while you come but you
cannot finish in the heart
i finished there but i can't finish here
hey nice buys finished last
exactly i don't hate i'm pretty fly for
a nice buy
not bad not bad is that is this we're
really reaching for these right now
we're really it's my dream to have a
talk show called by [ __ ] um oh that's
fine
okay so back to you okay so basically
with that being said
like i always picture us in her room uh
because or in her place
um because that's where we are many of
the times where i
choke if you will you know what i mean
but either way i don't want to do
anything so i'm very i'm very i cannot
believe this is on off the record and
this is public and i'm talking it's off
the record so it's fine right
right those are none of the things i'm
saying is real exactly um yeah when you
watch this did it actually happen was it
a dream
yeah um so i i do picture us at her
place
and um you know like whether a
specific song is on and this is also me
just being such a an emotional woman and
like sentimental and like i really am a
uh hopeless romantic what's the what's
the song dojo no i can't play the song
that'll give away who the person is
okay what's what's the second feature
song on the album of the same artist no
um you're trying to try yourself so
basically uh i picture us
at our place and you know the song goes
on and just i even picture saying
specific things wow so you're like even
the seducing
not only it builds up right not only am
i a hopeless romantic but i'm also like
a creative so it's like i i i have these
specific words that i feel like
would be so beautiful and special in the
moment and like cowabunga
sometimes i do that when you're not you
just like
no do you smell what the rock is cooking
that's that's oh nice wow
yeah so so i not the same category at
all
i thought i was thinking wait that is oh
go again wait the
so that's what i'm going to say to this
girl when the candles are lit
and i'm looking at her dead and i'm
saying brother
no but yeah i really picture this whole
but sometimes i don't sometimes i
if i just wanna get off i just um rub
one out you know before i go to trader
joe's
i don't need visuals or no no not at all
huh sometimes no yeah
wow sometimes when i'm just laying there
i'm like i kind of feel like
you know knocking one out treating
myself you know self-care
i'll just do it uh without that you know
five hours when it's the self-care and
just knock one out is it guy or a girl
in your brain can only be one it depends
on if there's someone i'm thinking about
like the other night i was at a birthday
dinner at cheesecake factory and i sat
across from a guy that i met for the
first time and like it
i i was treating like a first [ __ ]
day like i was
i was really into him um and i walked
away thinking
well you know i'm really insane yeah so
you know what's interesting because i'm
such a
so you masturbate to real people she's
very an emotional experience she has a
spank baby what do you masturbate to
stars or whatever
she's like at the bank nice to meet you
i will [ __ ] you later
that's a 1940s way of masturbating dude
she's old school
she's vintage they saw a flip book in
their head oh yeah bart master based the
cartoons the bar basketball is the
[ __ ] eliza thornberry
[ __ ] marge simpson
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you